the protection of personal information
and privacy in general has become a
source of concern in today's digital
world cryptography is an essential
feature of modern data security as it
allows the secure storage and
transmission of data between devices so
if you're interested in learning the art
of encryption and knowing how to apply
suitable encryption for different
scenarios here we are to help you with
that get prepared to understand the
basics of cryptography with us simply
learns skill up course provides the best
introduction to cryptography the best
part about it is that it is free yes you
can start your cryptography learning
journey free of cost and get a course
completion certificate for the same let
me take you through the details of our
free cryptography for beginners course
simply learn scale-up course on
introduction to cryptography targets
beginners who aspire to learn
cryptography and encryption here you
will explore cryptography with
significance and its applications the
topics covered in this course are what
is cryptography symmetric and asymmetric
key cryptography hashing ds and aes
algorithms dsa rsa md5 algorithm hash
algorithm ssl handshake a few frequently
asked interview questions and more this
program helps you get acquainted with
what goes into the art of encryption the
course is three hours long and all the
modules in it are self-paced video
lessons with 90 days of access to the
entire course this allows you to learn
at your own pace anytime anywhere after
completing this course you're awarded a
course completion certificate by
simplylearn this certificate can be
shared within your professional circle
so now you might be thinking who is
eligible to take this course right well
there are no prerequisites to enroll in
this course each of you who has a zeal
for learning how cryptography works can
take up this course irrespective of your
experience experienced industry experts
have specially designed this
well-structured beginner's course to
enable a smooth learning journey
skillups introductory course is also
recommended for those who know cyber
security but are looking to re-skill
themselves this course caters to cyber
security enthusiasts i.t security
professionals aspiring software
developers data scientists and security
engineers to name a few by the end of
this cryptography course you will be
well versed with the various methods to
employ cryptography in the real world so
what are you waiting for head straight
to our scala page and enrich your
cryptography knowledge by enrolling in
our free introduction to cryptography
for beginners course certifications
bring you one step closer to your dreams
and what can get better than a free
certificate to strengthen your profile
back the opportunity and become a cyber
security expert today
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here